tu as des salles complètes des mois à
l'avancé à 1,4 million d'abonnés sur un
start est devenue une rostane de ouf
alors j'aimerais faire une interview
depuis que tu as persie est ce que
depuis que tu as personnes arrêtent
souvent dans la rue pour faire des sales
fille très souvent quoi c'est devenu la
folie mais c'est tellement bien
j'aime tellement je kiffe mais j'ai
encore ce truc je suis très timide dans
la vie de tous les jours et du coup à
chaque fois quand on vous avait un moi
j'ai eu l'impression que c'est une pote
à moi du lycée que j'ai oublié c'est
quand on vient me voir dans la echl ah
ouais je la rappelle toi de son prénom
rappelle pas du tout mais ça me fait
tellement plaisir j'adore les moments de
celle fille parce que vous avez toujours
le moment de celle fille ou la personne
et des fois y'a les aider mais qd voilà
qui savent pas en fait tu avais ils sont
cammas à temps il reste maintenant deux
minutes n'ont battu vous annoncer qu'à
charge et le mec tu sers comme à quoi ça
m'arrivait et genre le mec crs cinq
minutes dont il attend non non non
patrick vial tu fais la capitale il fait
beaucoup de 100 kg telles attaques at on
besoin demande à tous alors moi je les
refuse tous pousser des polaroïds ont
demandé polar demande mais c'est le film
et les gens disent je suis moche on la
refait non ah ouais je suis je suis au
kebab où je vais souvent ah oui
exactement
vous voulez mais c'est vrai ces montants
demandés selphy d'aubaine ne faut pas se
moquer de mes faibles atp mais peu
importe mais c'est que les gens sont
contents de nous voir et j'ai un
privilège du coup maintenant au kebab
c'est une vraie histoire c'est que quand
on évoquait avant demain deux sauces en
général tomates oignons et ses tomates
mailloches et jacques maillot et bunge
et aura une troisième source non rien du
tout alors que d'habitude le chef il
embrouille les gens assez bon ces deux
sources
et donc maintenant grâce à tpm et btp
[Applaudissements]
toliver novelli de morsent oui large
partie aux restos et j'étais très bien
accueillis alors j'ai payé un bateau
très - matthew je paye les restos mais
on m'a dit je vous mets à table de vote
chef away et j'ai dit mais c'est qu'ils
m'ont chef c'est qui votre chef c'est
nous narre débat cyril hanouna
donc voilà donc je suis allé dans un
resto vous allez souvent et j'ai été
très bien accueilli
je les remercie et je rappelle ce n'est
pas le cas pays se moquer pays c'est
vrai que c'était un peu tôt les débats
tout cas ce qu'on voit c'est que vous
avez fait vous êtes allés au restaurant
semble parfois mais c'est peut-être pas
la dernière il ya un bail y avait toutes
mes gosses qui avait ses copines et vous
êtes sûr à une copine de kms de mia sont
très gentils elle symbolise atur une
copine de calais j'aurais aimé qu'ils
sahel sont trop jeunes est un état annie
a non non et l'ani d'allawi à mentir à
cyril pas
[Applaudissements]
kelly est ce que vous voulez aller
chercher anita ouais c'est vrai bashary
vous allez ans l'âge non mais beaucoup
trop jolie battre jeune mais très très
dur a été de dire des bêtises avait pas
si l'homme est jamais trop de ces jeunes
alors elle a trente ans passés bon chéri
bien non mais ça va à laval après on va
voir et ben on va voir on va voir on va
faire la connaissance d'anita battu
voyez on apprend des choses dans cette
émission